[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصفه الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور المباشره تريدنا
من نيام عاصمه النيجر وكثير من الاخبار
المرتقبه على وقع ازمه الانقلاب المستمره
مباره جزائريه للحل وما بعد مهله طرد
السفير الفرنسي
وهذه الصور تردنا من فلوريدا الامريكيه
التي تترقب اعصارا مع مخاوف كبيره من
تداعياته حيث اعلنت السلطات الولايه فتح
عشرات الملاجئ من اجل ايواء سكان المناطق
المتضرره
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد حراك دبلوماسي متسارع الجزائر تدخل
رسميا على خط الازمه في النيجر وتعلن عن
مبادره فتره انتقاليه برئاسه مدنيه
وضمانات لكل الاطراف صمت من نيامي
والايقوس والاتحاد الافريقي تحذير فرنسي
من انهيار امني في المنطقه ونائبه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي تنهي محادثات افريقيه
لاول مره منذ اندلاع الصراع البرهان في
تحرك خارج حدود السودان لقاء مع الرئيس
المصري في العلمين حديث عن طروحات تسويه
تتضمن فتره انتقاليه تفضي الى انتخابات
حره ونزيهه والسيسي يبدل التزام القاهره
بدعم امن السودان واستقراره
القوات الاوكرانيه تعلن تقدما في الجنوب
وتساعد هجماتها في منطقه البحر الاسود
تؤكد حصولها على ضوء اخضر لاستهداف القرد
والكريم لن يحذر الغرب من تكلفه باهظه بعد
اتهام دول بتوفير معلومات عن اهداف روسيه
تعلن حزمه مساعدات تتضمن صواريخ موجهه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التحرك الاول لرئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان خارج السودان
حيث التقى الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي في مدينه العلمين لاستطاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي هل ستؤدي تحركات البرهان
الى تغير في شكل الحراك الدولي والاقليمي
تجاه الصراع في السودان
49% قالوا نعم
و51% قالوا انه لن يحدث اي تغيير هذا
السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلال لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعنا في الحصاد ايضا
قبل ساعات من اجتماع مجلس الامن لتمديد
مهمتها جدل بشان مهام قوات اليونيفرس في
لبنان
[موسيقى]
في خضم نذري تدخل عسكري تتصاعد في النيجر
وما يبدو انسدادا سياسيا في التحركات
الراميه لايجاد حل لازمه الانقلاب اعلن
وزير الخارجيه الجزائري احمد عطاف عن
مبادره لحل سياسي في النيجر مدتها سته
اشهر تصريحاته تاتي في ظل صمت من نيامي
لدى قاده الانقلاب وكذلك في ابوجا مقر
مجموعه اكوس
بموازاه مقاربه
الانقلاب في النيجر كانت الجزائر الجاره
الشماليه تتحرك بدورها على عده محاور
بمقاربه رافضه لاي تدخل عسكري زارت وفول
عنها نيامي وقضت زياره وزيره خارجيتها الى
كل من نيجيريا وبينين وغانا وقبلها كانت
زيارته لوشنطن في هذا التوقيت الحساس حراك
وجد الزعما له خصوصا من ايطاليا حاله
الاستعصاء القائمه طرحت مبادره للحل من
سته محاور صياغه ترتيبات سياسيه
بمشاركه وموافقه جميع الاطراف
في النيجر
دون اقصاء لاي جهه مهما كانت
الايه على ان لا تتجاوز مده هذه الترتيبات
السته اشهر مثل ما سبق ذكره
وتكون تحت اشراف سلطه مدنيه
تتولاها شخصيه توافقيه
مبادره بدت الاكثر وضوحا حتى الان فيما
يتعلق بازمه النيجر ترافقها اسئله ان كانت
ستحظى بغطاء اقليمي ودولي يمنحها فرصه
العيش والنجاح خصوصا ان شظايا اي تدخل
عسكري ستنال النيجر والمنطقه برمتها
مبادره تاتي وقد توالت التطورات طوال شهر
كامل منذ انقلاب السادس والعشرين من يوليو
في النيجر وتسابقت في ذلك المواقف التي
كادت تكون مجمعه على رفض الانقلاب
والمطالبه بعوده نظام دستوري الا من موقفي
مالي وبوركينا فاسو الداعمتين لسلطات
الانقلاب وكل ذلك الحراك كان بالتوازي مع
نظر التدخل عسكري انقسمت بشانه دول
الاقليم وحتى الدول الكبرى اجتمع رؤساء
دول المجموعه الاقتصاديه لغرب افريقيا
وانتهوا الى اجازه استخدام القوه في حال
عدم عوده بازون الى منصبه في غضون اسبوع
والتقى قاده اركانهم لاحقا وحدت الساعه
الصفر للتدخل العسكري دون اعلانها بعد
خمسه ايام من الانقلاب وصل الرئيس تشادي
محمد ادريس للقاء قاده الانقلاب والرئيس
المحتجاز محمد بازوم بعد ان عرض الوساطه
لانهاء الازمه انقضت المهله الممنوحه من
اكواس ليعود للحكم ولم يعد تلتقي المجموعه
مره ثانيه في قمه في العاشر من اب اغسطس
لتمنح الدبلوماسيه متنافسا اخر استمر وصول
الوفود بينها الامم المتحده التي سرعت
لتحاول بدورها اختراق المشهد القائم وتجنب
تصعيد في المواقف وتلحقت زياره وفوذ من
اكواس قادها رئيس نيجيريا السابق عبد
السلام ابو بكر وتحرك بالتوازي وفد من
علماء نيجيريا اخر اللقاءات مع قائد
الانقلاب عبد الرحمن تياني والرئيس
المحتجز محمد بازوم وصفها ابو بكر
بالمثمره للغايه فشكلت تصريح جرعه امل
عسيتم تجنب الاسوا لكن في اليوم ذاته جاء
اعلان تيان اتجاهه لتشكيل حكومه انتقاليه
لمده لا تزيد على ثلاث سنوات واجراء حوار
وطني شامل وجد مقترح السلطات الانقلاب
رفضا من اكواس وفي الاثناء تميز موقفان
دوليان من الازمه فهواشنطن بدات تمسك
العصا من الوسط وكانت ارسلت مسؤولين عنها
وفضلت ان ترسل سفيرتها الجديده هناك
واعتبر وزير خارجيتها ان النهج
الدبلوماسيه هو السبيل الافضل مع دعم عوده
بازون والمسار الدستوري لكنها مقاربه
مختلفه عن فرنسا التي طلب قاده الانقلاب
من سفيرها المغادره واصرت على بقائه فيما
يشبه تحديا لسلطات الامر الواقع باريس بدت
متحفزه للحسم العسكري وهي المتضرر الاكبر
لما يحدث في النيجر من حيث وجود قواعدها
العسكريه او مصالحها الاقتصاديه بين كل
هذه المواقف هل تحدث مبادره الجزائر
لاختراق المامول في ازمه النيجر
هذا وتكثف قوات الانف النيجر حضورها في
محيط السفاره الفرنسيه في العاصمه نيام
لليوم الثاني على التوالي بعد انقضاء
المهله التي منحها المجلس العسكري للسفير
الفرنسي لمغادره البلاد ويجري افراد شرطه
النيجر عمليات تفتيش للسيارات والمركبات
الداخله والخارجه من السفاره قبل السماح
لها بالمرور يتزامن هذا مع دعوات اطلقتها
منظمات محليه داعمه للانقلاب العسكري لقطع
امدادات الكهرباء والمياه عن السفاره
وكانت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونا قد جددت المطالبه بعوده النظام
الدستوري وقالت الوزيره الفرنسيه ان
الانقلاب سيفشل وحذرت الوزيره الفرنسيه من
خطر الانهيار الامني في غرب افريقيا
وتفاقم الازمات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
حسب قولها
نطالب بالعوده الى النظام الدستوري في
النيجر نحن ملتزمون بيفاء مبدا
الديمقراطيه ولا يوجد انقلابيون يتحلون
بالديمقراطيه لا يمكن ان نتجاهل ما تقوله
اكواس بشان الوضع في النيجر ولا يمكننا
الاستمرار على نهج مالي وبرك نافاسو
الاحداث الاخيره تؤكد لنا ان المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه مهمه والانقلابيون سيفشلون
وهم يفشلوا بالفعل
يخيم التكتم على نتائج جوله مساعدتي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون الافريقيه الى
المنطقه والتي تنتهي اليوم وكانت المسؤوله
الامريكيه قد زارت كلا من نيجيريا وتشاد
وغانا كما اجرت مساعده الوزير مشاورات مع
مسؤولين رافعين مستوى في بنين
لمجموعه ايكوس حسب بيان الخارجيه
الامريكيه وتعتبر هذه الزياره الثانيه
لمسؤول امريكي رفيع بعد اسبوعين من زياره
القائمه باعمال نائب وزير الخارجيه
فيكتوريا نولاند الى النيجر اذربت نولد عن
قلقها ازاء التطورات في البلاد مطالبه
بالافراج الفوري عن الرئيس محمد بازوم
والمعتقلين ضمن محاوله الاستيلاء على
السلطه بصوره غير دستوريه بحسب بيان
الخارجيه الامريكيه
ينضم الينا من ابوجا ديفيد اوتو انديلي
مدير مركز جنيف للامن والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا ومن بريكسل مع
الاسفير جيمز موران المستشار السابق في
دائره العمل الخارجي للاتحاد الاوروبي
مرحبا بكما سيد ديفيد اوتو انديلي كيف
وجدت هذه المبادره المطروحه من جانب
الجزائر
هذا
التزام فردي احادي من الجزائر والجزائر هي
احد البلدان السبعه التي لها حدود
استراتيجيه مع النيجر الجزائر هي عضو في
الاتحاد المغاربي
وليست تعدرا في اكواس وبالنسبه لاكواس اذا
كان هناك اي تدخل عسكري فسيكون له تاثير
كبير
وكذلك الامر بالنسبه للجزائر فيما يتعلق
بالاجئين
اذا
الجزائر
مشاركه في عده
كيف تعتقد يمكن للايكوس ان تتعاطى مع هذه
المبادره لا سيما فيما يتعلق بانها يعني
تقدم حلا وسطا بين عدم عوده الرئيس بازون
وعدم استمرار المجلس العسكري في مهامه
وراهن الامور
بفتره انتقاليه تمتد لسته اشهر
يتولاها شخصيه مدنيه مقبوله من جميع
الاطراف
العسكريون تحدثوا عن ثلاثه
سنوات وكنا ننتظر موقف نعم الحكومه
الجزائريه اقترحت
سته شهور ولكن الامر لا يعود الى الجزائر
ينبغي ان يكون هناك توافق بين النيجر
ومجموعه ينبغي ان يجدوا
موقفا يتفق عليه الجميع اذا ان بحسب
المفاوضات بين النيجر
ولكنني سعيد بكون الجزائر قامت بهذه
المبادره لبسته اشهر لكن ينبغي ان نستمع
الى موقف ايكواس واعتقد ان هذا سيكون ربما
عمليا بالنسبه لحكومه النيجر وانا اسالك
من موقعك عن رايك فيما يمكن ان يكون عليه
موقف ايكواس ولكن
قبل ان اعود اليك دعنا نذهب الى السفير
جيمز موران سيد جيمز موران باعتقادك كيف
يمكن للقوى الغربيه ان تتعاطى مع هذه
المبادره التي طرحتها الجزائر
اعتقد ان المتحدث مقر من السابق لاوانه ان
نتحدث عن ذلك الامر
ليتعلق
بالزمن ولكن ايضا الشخصيات
من سيشرف على هذه الفتره الانتقاليه
ولا نعرف ما هي ردود فعل ايكواس ولا حكومه
النيجر اعتقد ان هناك معضله هنا بالنسبه
لكواس التي تعتبر ان التدخل العسكري
فقط للتوقف عند موضوع المبادره يعني
المبادره كانت واضحه عندما طرحها وزير
الخارجيه الجزائري بالقول ان هناك فتره
انتقاليه تمتد لسته اشهر يتولى هذه الفتره
الانتقاليه شخصيه مدنيه مقبوله من الجميع
انا اسالك عن المبدا بالمبدا هل تعتقد ان
هكذا مبادره يمكن ان تلقى قبولا من القوى
الغربيه
نعم ممكن ان تقبل لان الجميع يبحث عن طريق
للخروج من الازمه في النيجر في الوقت
الحاضر
وبحسب كيف سيتم اختيار هذه الشخصيه
المدنيه يمكن ان يكون هناك الشخصيات لها
قبول في اوروبا وفي مناطق اخرى
لكن لا ينبغي ان ننسى انه في اوروبا وفي
المجتمع الدولي
الرئيس المنتخب ما يزال موجودا وهو
قائد البلد وقبول ذلك معناه اننا لدينا
لا ندافع عن الديمقراطيه في النيجر وهذا
قد لا يقبله بعض البلدان في الغرب وكذلك
من نيجيريا وبلدان اخرى
اتخذت تدافع عن
الدستور
اذا كانت الظروف مواتير ربما يكون هذا
مخرجا سيد ديفيد
بالمبدا كذلك هل تعتقد ان هذه المبادره في
الشق المتعلق كما ذكرت لك بموضوع الفتره
الانتقاليه الممتده لسته اشهر هل يمكن
ربما ان تناقش او تلقى قبولا من جانب
قبولا مبدئيا على الاقل من جانب
لا يمكنني ان اتوقع ما ستقبله
لم تقم باي تعليق على هذه المبادره
ويقولون انهم لا يقبلون ثلاث سنوات
[موسيقى]
لكن الامر يرتبط
بالمساله العمليه التطبيقيه هل من الممكن
للعسكريين ان ينظموا انتخابات خلال سته
شهور لا اعتقد ان ذلك سيكون ممكنا من
ناحيه من الناحيه العمليه
ربما نجد انفسنا في وضع ان نقبله ولكن بعد
سته شهور لا يكون كل شيء جاهزا لتنظيم
الانتخابات اذا حتى يكون
المبادره واقعيه ينبغي ان نرى ان الحكومه
ان حكومه في النيجر يمكنها ان تفعل ذلك
والدول الاخرى مثل مالي التي قررت 18 شهرا
وبوركينا فاسو تقريبا نفس المده اذا ينبغي
ان نكون عمليين في الوقت الفتره الزمنيه
اللازمه
ما هي الظروف التي ستتم فيها
وستسحب هذه الفتره سته شهور مثلا هناك
الشخصيات لا يسمح لها بان تكون
عضوا او يكون اعضائها مشاركين في الحكومه
وان هل ان كل العقوبات ينبغي ان يتم
اسقاطها اذا هناك عده امور ينبغي النظر
فيها حتى نعرف ما اذا كان ذلك سيكون
مقبولا شكرا لكم
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا
والمستشار جيمز موران السفير جيمز موران
المستشار السابق في دائره العمل الخارجي
للاتحاد الاوروبي ضيفنا من بروكسل
[موسيقى]
عاد رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان عبد
الفتاح البرهان الى مدينه بورتسودان بعد
اول زياره خارجيه له منذ اندلاع المواجهات
قادته الى مصر وكان البرهان قد بحث مع
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي في
العلمين التطورات وجهود حل الازمه
الراهنه في السودان وقال البرهان ان الجيش
حريص على وضع حد للحرب في بلاده وملتزم
باقامه فتره انتقاليه حقيقيه تفضي الى
انتخابات حره ونزيهه
يخطو البرهان اولى خطواته خارج السودان
لاول مره منذ اربعه اشهر في مدينه العلمين
بحث مع الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
جهود المبذوله لتسويه الازمه السودانيه
بما يحفظ امن البلاد واستقرارها وتماسكها
وفق ما ورد في بيان مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في السودان
ربما تكون زياره البرهان مجرد بدايه لحاره
دبلوماسي تسعى من خلاله قياده الجيش لخلق
زخم اقليمي داعم لرؤيته في سبيل وضع حد
للمعارك من خلال مرحله انتقاليه سياسيه
يقول البرهان انه ملتزم بها نحن حريصين
كانوا في اننا نضع حد لهذه الحرب ونضع حد
لانه هذا هذه الماسات تنتهي نحن في الجيش
القوات المسلحه السودانيه ملتزمين باننا
ما نسعى الى
اقامه فتره انتقاليه حقيقيه يستطيع بعدها
الشعب ان يؤسس دولته من خلال انتخابات حره
نزيهه يختار فيها الشعب السوداني
من يريد ان يحكم ياتي هذا بعدما كان قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حميدتي قد
دعا لاقامه حكم فيدرالي قال انه سينهي
حروب السودان كلها في الرؤيه التي قدمها
قال ان اي مفاوضات تهدف للتسويه يجب ان
تقوم على البحث عن حل سياسي شامل وان تدرج
فيها بنود تشمل اعتمادا نظام حكم فيدرالي
وحكومه مدنيه تمثل كل اقاليم السودان
وطالب حميدتي باقرار تاسيس جيش سوداني
جديد وتصفيه الوجود الحزبي والسياسي داخل
هياكله حديث الدبلوماسيه المحتمله يواجهه
ميدان محتدم فما يزال الوضع يضج بالمعارك
ويزيد الماساه الانسانيه عمقا في مدينه
نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور سقط ما لا
يقل عن 39 قتيلا جراء سقوط قذائف على
منازل مدنيين بينما يحتدم القتال في اقليم
جنوب كردفان بين الجيش وقوات الحركه
الشعبيه شمال جناح عبد العزيز لحلو وقد
اسفرت عن مقتل عشرين عنصرا في الحركه
الشعبيه حسب مصادر عسكريه للجزيره اما في
العاصمه الخرطوم فتجدد اطلاق النار في
المنطقه الفاصله بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع
معنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديميه السوداني المختص في
الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه مرحبا بك دكتور
اسامه البرهان في مصر يطرح
موضوع فتره انتقاليه وانتخابات اين موقع
كل ذلك من البحث عن حل
للمازق عن حل المواجهات العسكريه
قطعا زياره البرهان نفسها لمصر هي جزء من
في اطار ايقاف الحرب بكاملها
تذكرين انه مصر تدخلت في وقت مناسب جدا
كانت بعض دول جوار السودان تتحدث انه
السودان
دوله بلا حكومه
وتدعو الى
منطقه منزوعه السلاح ايقاف الطيران خرطوم
خاليه من الجيش يعني اشياء تضرب في عمق
السياده السودانيه نفسها
مصر تدخلت وقام مؤتمر دول جوار السودان
يعني بما يحفظ للسودان سيادته بعد هذه
المبادره
واتاحت الفرصه للدوله السودانيه ان تستمر
في في حسم التمرد الموجود في الخرطوم
بالاضافه الى ان تقوم باجراءات من اجل وقف
الحرب عبر المفاوضات في مبادره جده وغيرها
من المبادرات الكثيره الموجوده خروج
البرهان اليوم واستقبال مصر له يؤكد ان
الدوله السودانيه رغم هذا يعني هذه
المصيبه الكبيره مصيبه الحرب التي دارت في
وسط الخرطوم يعني الدوله السودانيه تؤكد
انها دوله قويه ودوله راسخه
كل ذلك اين موقعه في البحث عن حل
للمواجهات العسكريه هي المواجهات العسكريه
والحسم العسكري واحد من وسائل ايقاف
المعركه نفسها يعني هذه المعركه اما ان
تقف بالحسم العسكري في الخرطوم
قطعا جزء من محادثات البرهان وجولاته
الخارجيه والداخليه وكذلك جزء من
منها هو البحث عن عن يعني نصير
لاجبار حركه التمرد هذه التي تحارب اليوم
الشعب السوداني كله يعني لانه خط خط
المبادره
لايقاف هذه الحرب كان واضحا في شرط
اتفاقيه جده التي قضت بخروج الدعم السريع
وقواته من منازل المدنيين الحسم العسكري
تقول دكتور اسامه هي هو جزء من الحل وهذا
ايضا ما يقوله البرهان بالامس في
بورتسودان يتحدث عن انه يجب القضاء على
هذا التمرد ولكن اليوم في مصر يقول انه
حريص على انهاء الحرب كيف يحرص على انهاء
الحرب
والمواجهات والبحث عن حل على الاقل غير
موجود يعني
الحسم العسكري يقسم المعركه العسكريه لكن
لا يقضي على العسكريه مستمره منذ اشهر ولم
يتمكن اي طرف من حسمها هو الان الجيش يحسم
هذه المعرفه العسكريه هذه المعركه
العسكريه بدات في كل السودان والان اصبحت
هي معركه حول السلاح المدرعات في الخرطوم
يعني اي مراقب يستطيع ان يرى انحسار هذه
الحرب كبير من كل اطراف السودان والان
صارت مجرد معركه في منطقه الشجره في
الخرطوم ليس هنالك معارك بمعنى انه الدعم
السريع لا يستطيع ولا يملك القوه في ان
يشن هجوم عسكري جديد في هذه
الدكتور اسامه البرهان عاد الان الى بورت
سودان كان هناك حديث عن ان هذه الجوله
الخارجيه ستشمل بلدان اخرى هل انتهى الامر
عند القاهره باعتقادك ام هناك اكثر انا
انا لا اتكهن ولا اعتقد لكن البرهان الان
يدير
الدوله ويعود دولاب الدوله للعمل دولاب
الدوله عندما يعود للعمل سيكون هنالك على
البرهان مهام مهمه ودولاب الدوله يقوم بها
هي تخفيف حده معاناه المدنيين السودانيين
بالاضافه الى ايقاف هذا التمرد الكبير على
الشعب السوداني وبالتالي كل ما يتطلبه ذلك
سيقوم به البرهان في الفتره القادمه اشكرك
جزيل الشكر دكتور اسامه العيدروس
الاكاديميه السودانيه مختص في الشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه ضيفنا هنا في استديو
الحصاد شكرا
[موسيقى]
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوتها
تتقدم باتجاه مدينه ميليتوبل في مقاطعه
زابولوجيا تزامنا مع اعلان البيت الابيض
تقديم حزمه مساعدات امريكيه جديده لدعم
دفعات اوكرانيا الجويه اضافه الى ذخائر
وعتاد وقال مستشار الرئاسه الاوكراني اخذت
ضوء اخضر من شركائها لشلها هجمات على شبه
جزيره القرم اما في موسكو فتوعد الكريم
الغرب بدفع تكلفه باهظه
الى القرم من جديد تتجه اعين السياسيين
والعسكريين في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
يزيد الاوكرانيون من كثافه هجماتهم فوق
شبه الجزيره اقصى جنوبي البلاد تلك جزيره
تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ عام 2014 وتؤكد
انها اراضي روسيه خالصه في مقابل رفض
اوكراني وتاكيد انها لن تصبح روسيه
بالتقادم في الساعات الماضيه تعلن وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجومين اوكرانيين
كانا يستهدفان منشات داخل روسيا لمسيارتين
جرى اسقاطهما في المجال الجوي فوق مياه
البحر الاسود على الارض تقول كييف انها
تواصل عملياتها الهجوميه باتجاه مدينه بول
جنوبي البلاد تلك مدينه تعتبر بوابه الى
شبه جزيره القبر تقع من تبول على خط سكه
حديد يربط روسيا بالقرن والاراضي الاخرى
التي تسيطر عليها جنوبيه اوكرانيا تمت
اهداف كثيره لاوكرانيا في القرن مو مطارات
مدنيه وعسكريه وقواعد جويه وبحريه ومنشات
حيويه للوجود الروسي في شبه الجزيره الاهم
في هذا كله ميناء سيفاستوبول مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي يدي روسيا طولا نحو
المياه الدافئه يوازيه في الاهميه جسر
القرن او كيريتش الذي يربط شبه الجزيره
بالاراضي الروسيه ويعتبر خط الامداد
للقوات الروسيه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
بالكامل اكتوبر الماضي هاجمت المخابرات
الاوكرانيه جسر كيرتش للمره الاولى منذ
اندلاع الحرب فردت موسكو بقصف كييف بعد
امتناع عن ذلك لاشهر بعد بدء الحرب اليوم
يؤكد المستشار في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
الامر تغير
اليوم لدينا الامكانيات لتدمير كل شيء
روسي في شبه جزيره القرم اذكركم العمل
ماضي كان هناك اعتراض على هذا ولكن الان
اذا اخذنا في الاعتبار عدد الدول التي
تدعمنا في هذا الاطار فاننا نستطيع تدمير
كل شيء روسي في الاراضي المحتله
يعتبر نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
ان هذا الضوء الغربي سيكون سببا لشن حرب
اوسع وسيمنح موسكو اطارا قانونيا للتحرك
ضد الجميع تتهم موسكو الغرب بتسهيل
العمليات الاوكرانيه ضد الاهداف الروسيه
في القرد فوق البحر الاسود تلاحق مقاتله
سوخوي 30 الروسيه مسيره ريبر الامريكيه
وتمنعها من دخول الاجواء الروسيه فوق
القرد قبل اشهر معدوده تعلن موسكو اسقاط
مسيره امريكيه في الاجواء ذاتها ووفق
الاتهامات الروسيه فان المسيره الامريكيه
تزود الاوكرانيين بالمعلومات اللازمه
لاستهداف المواقع الروسيه في
في البحر تعلن كييف للمره الاولى تشكيله
واحده منفصله للمسيرات البحريه يؤكد رئيس
جهاز امن الدوله الاوكرانيه ان هدف هذه
الوحده هو استهداف جسر القرم والقطع
البحريه الروسيه في البحر الاسود وبين كون
القرم عمق الروسيه ام ارضا اوكرانيه محتله
تراوح المواقف الاوكرانيه يشير الرئيسكي
لان استهداف العمق الروسي سيجعل
الاوكرانيين يواجهون مصيرهم وحدهم لكن
وزيره خارجيته يوضح اليوم ان الاوكرانيين
جاهزون للمضي قدما في استهداف العمق
الروسي وفي مقدمته القرد هكذا تتحول القرم
الى عنوان مهم في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
مع ضوء اخضر غربي تتحدث عنه كييف وتحذير
روسي من قلب المعادله
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء فايز اذا
اوكرانيا تتحدث عن ضوء اخضر غربي لكي
تستطيع عشان هجمات على القرم ما شكل
المعركه باعتقادك التي
ستتخذها هذه الهجمات على القرد
يعني هذه الهجمات هي بدات منذ اشهر بدات
في الهجوم على جسر كيرش اولا
والهجوم الثاني على جسم جسر كيرش هناك
هجمات
متتاليه متصاعده سواء على منطقه
على بعض المحطات الرادار بعض قواعد
الامداد اللوجستي اذا دعيني اقول خلال
الفتره الماضيه هناك تواتر في الغارات
ولكن يتباين عدد هذه الغارات والفاصل
الزمني بينها وهذا مرتبط بالظروف
الاستخباريه والقدرات على ارسال
المسيرات او استخدام صواريخ ظل العاصفه
البريطانيه من قبل سلاح الجو الاوكراني
اذا التصعيد سيكون مستمر ومتواتر بهذه
القدرات الطائرات المسيره استخدام صواريخ
او استخدام المسيرات البحريه
حديث عن معارك بريه لا يزال الحديث مبكر
جدا لماذا لان لا تزال هناك مسافه طويله
بين مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه في اوريخ او ما حولها وما
بينسك المسافه 80 كيلو متر تبعد القوات
الاوكرانيه عن ميليتوبل ومئه كيلو متر عن
شواطئ بحر اسوف الان الحديث عن تقدم يقاس
بمئات الامتار بمساحات كيلو متر مربع
اربعه كيلو متر مربع اذا لا يزال الحديث
مبكر عن معارك بريه يعول على الاختراق
الحالي في منطقه جبولوجيا اذا قيظ له ان
ينجح
كيف يمكن لروسيا ان تتعاطى مع هذا المعطى
الجديد المتمثل بالضوء الاخضر لاوكرانيا
بشن هجمات على القرد
يعني الضوء الاخضر هو اصلا العمليات
العسكريه في القرن كانت وفي الداخل الروسي
هي سابقه على الضوء الاخضر فالضوء الاخضر
هو جاء اعلانا عن
بعض الاجراءات العسكريه يعني في سابقا لم
يكن هناك اخضر فايز ان هذه الضربات على
القرم ستتكثف بشكل
يختلف عن السابق
انا قلت يعني الان يجب ان نحدد ما هي
الامكانات التي يمكن توظيفها انا قلت ان
الهجمات هي متواتره تتباين في شدتها او في
الفواصل الزمنيه بناء على معطيات ميدانيه
ولكن الان من حيث المبدا القرم تعتبر في
من وجهه نظر القانون الدولي اراضي
اوكرانيه منذ عام 1953 عندما قدمها هديه
الى اوكرانيا من اجل التعايش ما بين
الاوكران والروس في تلك في تلك المنطقه
وبالتالي القانون الدولي يعتبرها اراضي
محتله والرئيس بايدن وغيره جميعهم تحدثوا
عن حق اوكرانيا في قصف المناطق المحتله
اذن هنا الجديد هو التسميه استخدم لفظ شبه
جزيره القرم في التصريحات انما بالاصل هي
الكل وافق على هذا الاجراء العسكري شكرا
لك الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان
اعتقلت السلطات الالمانيه رجل اعمال
المانيا روسيا لبيعه مكونات الكترونيه
تستخدم في المعدات العسكريه لروسيا وذكر
المدعون الفيدراليون ان المشتبه فيه اجرى
26 عمليه تصدير في الفتره بين عامي 2020
لشركه في روسيا واوضح المدعون الفيدراليون
ان المكونات الالكترونيه التي صدرها من
خلال شركته في غرب المانيا تستخدم في
طائرات مسيره تستعملها روسيا في حربها على
اوكرانيا وحسب تقديرات ممثلي الادعاء فان
قيمه التجاره بين رجل الاعمال الالماني
وشركائه الروس تصل الى نحو 715 الف يورو
وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي قد ادرج ضمن اخر
حزمه عقوبات على روسيا اجراءات صارمه ضد
من يعيد تصدير التكنولوجيا التي يمكن
استخدامها في الحرب
لروسيا
معنى من
الضابط السابق في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطانيه وكبير الخبراء العسكريين في
مؤسسه جلوب ساك للدراسات سيد فرانك
كيف حدث هذا رغم كل العقوبات المفروضه على
روسيا
مساء الخير هذا سؤال ممتاز
الوقائع هنا او عوامل هنا اولا معظم
العالم لا يعاقب روسيا
اذا
استيراد
هذه الاجهزه الالكترونيه يمكن استيرادها
من اماكن عديده
بلدان القريبه من روسيا تاريخيا مثل دول
القوقاز ووسط اسيا كازاخستان وغيرها
والصين بطبيعه الحال
كلها
حره او لها حريه
تصدير هذه الرقائق الالكترونيه الى روسيا
هذا اول شيء الشيء الثاني
هل يمكن ان نقول من قبل جميع هذه
الشرائح انها عسكريه او وهي تستخدم وينبغي
ان تجد المال مع المال يمكنك ان تشتري اي
شيء وكل شيء متوفر في روسيا ولكن سيد
فرانك سيد فرانك ان كان ما حدث ليس
التفافا ولا خرقا على العقوبات لماذا تم
اعتقال الرجل واعتباره مجتبها به
انا متاكد من ان
الاستخبارات
تعمل مع الاستخبارات الامريكيه
وتحاول
ان تلعب دور شرطي وانه تم التحقيق في شبكه
التزويد
وتابعوا البلدان التي تفرض العقوبات في
اوروبا اذا هي عمليه استخبارات مع مستوى
عالي من الخبرات الالكترونيه طيب في هذا
الاطار سيد فرانك ما حجم هذه الصادرات
باعتقادك المستمره لروسيا والتي تساعد
روسيا في صناعتها العسكريه
الكثيرون لا يرون حلا لذلك هي محاوله
صيد الماء بشبكه او بغربال
العقوبات بشكل عام يمكن
مخالفتها
وانتهاكها حدث هذا مع العراق ومع روسيا
الان
البعض يعتقدون ان العقوبات دورها
قليل جدا او ضعيف جدا
والمال هو العصر
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من اكسفورد
الضابط السابق في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطانيه وكبير الخبراء العسكريين في
مؤسسه جلوبسات للدراسات
[موسيقى]
مثل المتهمون في القضيه التي عرفت اعلاميا
بطائره الذهب المشبوه مثل امام احدى محاكم
لوساكا عاصمه زامبيا وقررت المحكمه حبس
المتهمين احتياطيا رافضه الافراج عنهم
بكفاله من جهتها نقلت وكاله انباء الشرق
الاوسط الرسميه المصريه عن مصدر وصفته
بالمطلع قوله ان السلطات المصريه تنسق مع
نظيراتها الزامبيه وتتابع سلامه سير
اجراءات التحقيق معهم وكانت السلطات
الزامبيه اعلنت احتجاز طائره خاصه قادمه
من القاهره على متنها مبالغ ماليه بقيمه
نحو سته ملايين دولار
وسبائك قيل بدايه انها من الذهب قبل
الاعلان لاحقا انها معادن اخرى وقالت
السلطات الزامبيه انها وجهت للمتهمينه
تهمه التجسس ومن بينهم ضابط زامبي سابق في
مقاله وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان من بينهم
عسكريا مصريا سابقا ووفقا لما اعلنه مدير
لجنه مكافحه المخدرات في زامبيا فان
الموقوفين هم سته مصريين واسباني وهولندي
وزامبي ومواطن من لاتفيا ويواجه الموقفون
عقوبه السجن لمده تصل الى 30 عاما في حال
ادانتهم
معنا من لوساكا عاصمه زامبيا الفونسوكا
سونغو الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
مرحبا بك سيد الفونسو ماذا تقول لنا هذه
الاتهامات الموجهه بالنظر الى طبيعه
القضيه
مساء الخير نعم
لدينا هذه
الحادثه التي تدور حولها
لغه كثير كبير
هناك
بضاعه في علامتني تلك الطائره
في مطار لوساكا
نعم تفضل
وهناك عدد من البضائع التي او السلع التي
تم اكتشافها
كميه من
سبائك الذهب
وايضا المبالغ ماليه نقديه
وهذه
والحكومه تقوم بتحقيق في هذا الامر
عن طريق وكاله
التهريب
اذا اليوم او بالامس
راينا
المتهمين الذين
تم العثور عليهم
وسيتم عرضهم على المحاكم ونخشى
ان هؤلاء
المشبوهين
قد اخذوا الى المحاكم لانه لا يمكن ان
يحاكموا في بطرق اخرى سيد الفونسو السلطات
المصريه تقول انها تنسق مع السلطات في
زامبيا حول هذا الموضوع ما المعلومات حول
هذا التنسيق مع حدوده والى اين يمكن ان
يفضي
تنسيق قد يكون موجودا ولكن
الحكومه
الزامبيه هي التي تطبق
القانون قانون البلد
وينبغي ان تتم المحاكمه والنظر في هذه
القضيه من قبل السلطات الزامبيه
ونحن نسمع
ان هؤلاء المشبوهين
الذين من بينهم سته مصريين
وخمسه زمبيين
كانوا على علاقه
بالجوسسه او الاستخبارات والحكومه حريصه
على ان تطبق القانون
وحاله المشبوهين الى التحقيق والى
المحاكمه
شكرا لك الفونسو كاسونغو الكاتب الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي ضيفنا من لوساك عاصمه
زامبيا
يبحث مجلس الامن الدولي غدا الاربعاء
تمديد مهمه القوات الدوليه في جنوب لبنان
اليونيفل لعام اضافي وفقا للقرار الدولي
رقم 1701 الذي انهى حرب عام 2006 بين
اسرائيل وحزب الله ويسال لبنان الى الغاء
فقره من التفويض الممنوح لليونيفال تتيح
لها تنفيذ مهماتها دون مرافقه الجيش
اللبناني يتزامن ذلك مع توتر بين لبنان
واسرائيل على طول الحدود بينهم لا سيما في
مزارع شبعه وتلال كفر شوبا
تقوم هذه القوات الدوليه بمهمه روتينيه
عند الحدود لكن السلطات اللبنانيه وحزب
الله يتخوفان من تسييرها دوريات جنوب
البلاد دون مؤازره من الجيش وفق تعديل
ادخل على مهمات اليونيفيل العام الماضي
تؤكد القوات الدوليه انها تنسخ كامل
عملياتها مع الجيش وان 20% من دورياتها
تواكبها قوات منه ناتي
لم يتغير شيء بالنسبه لعمل قواتنا منذ عام
2006 من دون الجيش لكن من المهم التاكيد
اننا نبلغ الجيش دوما بمهامنا
يسعى لبنان الى الغاء التعديل الذي ادخله
مجلس الامن على تفويض كما يعمل على تاكيد
حقوقه في ثلاثه عشره نقطه حدوديه عند الخط
الازرق تبدا من الشاطئ وحتى المجيدي شرقا
بطول 80 كم يضاف اليها مزارع شبعه وتلال
كفرشوبه سواء تم التعديل على مهام قوات
اليونيفيل او بقيت على حالها الا ان ذلك
لا ينهي التوتر القائم على طول الحدود هنا
فلبنان يحذر من سعي اسرائيل تجريف وضم
اراضيه في عدد من النقاط الحدوديه واكثرها
حساسيه تلك التي تقع في تلالك فرشوبه
ومزارع شبعه والغجر
ففي محيط بلده الغجر السوريه التي اعلنت
اسرائيل ضمها مع الجولان المحتل يؤكد
لبنان ان جزءا من الامتداد العمراني لهذه
البلده يقع داخل اراضيه ويطالب من انسحاب
القوات الاسرائيليه منه رايحين للاجتماع
بالمندوبين الاعضاء او السفر الاعضاء
الدائمين في مجلس الامن لاقناهم بوجهه
نظرنا لناحيه الخلاف على الحدود وعلى
الخروعات الاسرائيليه الدائمه اللي عم
يعملوها يوميا وخاصه 17 دائم على الخط
الازرق
اكثر النقاط توترا تقع في مزارع شبعه حيث
نصب حزب الله خيمه في اراضي لبنانيه تقع
خارج ما يعرف بخط انسحاب القوات
الاسرائيليه وجاء ذلك بعد محاولات
اسرائيليه قد ما اراد اضافيه في امتلالك
فرشوبه المجاوره ما ادى الى استنفارات
متبادله الحدود بالالفين غير الحدود
بالالفين 2006 يعني بالالف سحبوا الى حدود
معينه
بالالفين 2006 تغيرت الخدود يعني في خط
هذا خط واقف اطلاق النار صاير خط مطاط
القوي هو بحركه حسب مصالحه متل ما بده
فلذلك صار في خروقات
هكذا اذا يسعى لبنان لادخال تعديلات على
التفويض الممنوحل وفي الوقت عينه يسعى
لتثبيت حقوقه وسط خشيه من تفاقم التوترات
التي قد تنهي ما تصف القوات الدوليه
بالاستقرار النسبي الذي تشوبه الخروقات
بين فتره واخرى
ايهاب العقد الجزيره جنوب لبنان
تفاصيل اضافيه سنتعرف عليها بشان قوات
اليونيفال قبل ان ندخل في النقاش بشان
مالات الخلاف غدا بالمبدا هي قوات طوارئ
دوليه نشرت في جنوب لبنان عام
1978 بموجب قرار دولي لكن الحضور اخذ صدا
اكبر عام 2006 بعد حرب تموز حيث تم تعزيز
القوات الدوليه بموجب قرار اممي هو القرار
1701 وبلغ اكبر عدد للقوات المشاركه
15,000ا في السنوات في السنوات سابقه لكنه
الان يتجاوز عشره الاف بقليل القوات
مهمتها مراقبه هذا الخط بطوله وهو يعرف
باسم الخط الازرق ومهمه القوات ايضا تتركز
على التاكد من خلوه هذه المنطقه بين الخط
ونهر الليطان من اي مظاهر مسلحه باستثناء
الجيش اللبناني الخلاف الذي يجري الحديث
عنه يتعلق بالفقره السادسه
تبلغ وزير الخارجيه من
ممثلين دول خمس موافقتهم عليها ايضا تضمن
استمرار حريه عمل قوات اليونيفل وبالتالي
تعني في طياتها ان هناك قرار دولي واقليمي
بعدم المس بدور هذه القوات وبالتالي عدم
المس بوقف اطلاق النار القائم منذ العام
1701 هناك نقاط عديده
شرحها لي معالي وزير الخارجيه منها ما
يتصل بموضوع
استبدال عباره الغجر ببلده الماري
الانسحاب الاسرائيلي من اطراف بلده الميري
الجنوبيه
اذا يعني بعتقد هذه هي ابرز
الفرنسي في موضوع التصويت ذكرت لنا ان
وزير الخارجيه ابلغك سيد حسين ان هناك
يعني تعديلات اجريت على هذا التفويض ولكن
سؤالي لماذا تريد
اليونيفل ان لا تنسق مع الجيش اللبناني في
دورياتها ما الهدف من وراء ذلك
حصل خلل في العام الماضي
وجرت مساءله لبنانيه للخلل الذي حصل بين
البعثه اللبنانيه في نيويورك والحكومه
اللبنانيه قيل انذاك ان الخطا اداري ادى
هذا الخطا الاداري الى تعديل لم يكن في
الحسبان بمعنى اعطاء تفويض لليونيفل بان
تتحرك من دون التنسيق مع الجيش على مدى
سنه كامله لم تقم اي دوريه للجيش لليونس
في الجنوب الا بالتنسيق مع الجيش اللبناني
مستمرا حتى الان اليس كذلك
الصيغه التي تم التوصل اليها الليله ترضي
جميع الاطراف بمعنى انها ابقت على عمل
اليونيفيل بشكل مستقل ولكنها بعباره ثانيه
بالتنسيق مع الحكومه اللبنانيه يعني ارضت
الطرفين الصيغه التي تم التوصل اليها
الليله المساله اعتباريه ومعنويه وليست
ماديه بمعنى لو اليوم مجلس الامن قرر
عدم القبول بالمنطقه اللبناني وذهب الى
الفصل السابع وقال ان اليونيف لا تريد ان
تنسق مع الجيش اللبناني وعنده حريه حركه
هل تستطيع اليونيفل تنفيذ هذا الامر بقوه
الوقائع القائمه على ارض الجنوب اعتقد
الجواب لا لا ننسى ان اليونيفل عندما اتت
في العام 2006 الى جنوب لبنان لم
لم تكن اي دوله مستعده لارسال اي جندي من
الجنود ال 14 الف اليونيف المعززه عم نحكي
بال 2006 الا بعد ان تواصلت مخابراتها مع
حزب الله ما الخشيه اللبنانيه سيد حسين من
ادخال او من بقاء الصيغه كما كانت في
العام الماضي لماذا يصر لبنان على ادخال
موضوع التنسيق سواء مع الجيش او مع السلطه
اللبنانيه بمعزل عن من هي
لان المساله كما قلت لك اعتباريه اسرائيل
قامت منذ العام 2006 حتى يومنا هذا باكثر
من 25 الف خرق فقط في الجو لان نحن لا
نتحدث عن خرقات في البحر او في البر كيف
تصرفت اليونسل او كيف تتصرف اليونيف مع
هذه الخروقات الاسرائيليه بمعنى انه ان
لبنان يخشى ان تكون اليونيفال فقط لا غير
حارس لامن اسرائيل من خلال اعطائها هامش
حريه حركه كبيره على ارض الجنوب اللبناني
وبالتالي اداره ظهرها للحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه
هل هذا مرتبط باعتقادك فقط بموضوع الخروق
الاسرائيليه يعني
ما الفارق الذي يمكن ان يحدثه تنسيق
مثل الذي نتحدث عنه ايذاء هذه الخروقات
بمعنى ان اليوم كما قلت لك
اليونسل المعززه لها دور في حمايه
المنظومه السلم الاقليمي في جنوب لبنان
يعني اي البعدين اللبناني والاسرائيلي وهي
تتولى التواصل مع الجهتين اللبنانيه
والاسرائيليه عندما يشعر اللبناني بان
المطلوب من اليونيفال ان تكون فقط لا غير
حارسه للحدود هذا الامر يمس الامن والسلم
الاهلي في لبنان كان مطلوبا من لبنان
الليله في نيويورك ان يوائم بين مقتضيات
السلم الاهلي اللبناني الذي تقتضي عدم
تثبيتها كعرف كمبدا وليس كانعبول حتى لو
تم اعتماد الصيغه تبع السنه الماضي او تم
تطويرها نحو صيغه اكثر تشددا منها هي غير
قابله للتطبيق المساله هي مساله مبدئيه
لذلك مقتضيات السلم الاهلي في لبنان كانت
تقتضي هذا التعديل وهون للمناسبه كان موقف
الحكومه اللبنانيه ممتاز جدا بمعنى كافيه
تناغم بين المؤسسات الدوله اللبنانيه
للتواصل الى الصيغه التي تم التوصل اليها
هذه الليله شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت حسين
ايوب الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه حصاد هذه الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم
وتصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]